your grouchy language Grandpa here again
to complain about language books grammar
books why do they make it so complicated
so here again this is this English
grammar book I think grammar books and
language learning books in general are
written for people who already know the
language so they talk about things that
you would only relate to if you already
had enough experience with the language
I don't know any page here polite
requests with you as the subject would
you will you could you if you get enough
exposure you know those things modals
degrees of certainty present time
degrees of certainty using wood to
express a repeated action in the past
all dealing with stuff in the language
that you either have experienced or you
haven't a waste of time